more changes coming to Saudi Arabia as
the kingdom grants new rights to women
new laws made public today allow women
to apply for a passport and travel
without permission from a male relative
Holly Williams is following the story
from Istanbul Holly how big of a deal is
this good morning well this will be
life-changing from any Saudi Arabian
women and let me explain why they still
live under the so-called male
guardianship system which means that
Saudi women need permission from a male
relative a father husband brother or son
to make key decisions about their own
lives but the powers of male Guardians
are gradually being stripped away
including now their right to dictate
whether women can travel overseas this
follows a string of high-profile cases
where Saudi women ran away from their
families somehow escaped overseas and
then sought asylum those cases have been
very embarrassing for the Saudi
authorities but let's remember there are
still several women's rights activists
in prison in Saudi Arabia and there are
accusations
they've been tortured and the leader
behind these changes Crown Prince
Mohammed bin Salman is widely suspected
of involvement in the killing of Jamal
hisagi Ashok ji was a journalist and
Saudi government critic who was killed
inside the Saudi consulate here in
Istanbul last year so the Crown Prince
is undoubtedly a social reformer but
Saudi Arabia is still a very long way
from being a free country Anthony a very
long way indeed Holly Williams in
Istanbul thanks Holly